Sony's virtual reality headset is on the  market now but will sales be up to the  company's expectations I'm Tony and this  game spot news update is flying off the  shelves PlayStation executive Jim Ryan  expects psv are to sell quote hundreds  of thousands of units at launch  pre-orders sold out quickly but you can  still purchase the headset at various  online and physical retailers Jim Ryan  also confirmed in an interview that Sony  is ramping up production additionally  research groups super data even  predicted the PS VR could reach 2.6  million units sold by the end of the  year the PS VR headset costs 400 bucks  by itself a price point which Jim Ryan  calls quote extremely affordable you can  also pick up a five-hundred-dollar  bundle with everything you need to get  started if you need a little more help  making up your mind check out GameSpot's  psv our review and for all the biggest  VR news you're already in the right  place  you